what do you uh I'm I'm an investor of
yours so you're um I don't forget how
much I invested but you're like
well I don't really invest in anything
other than like van like total index
funds and but you're like one of the few
I think you're one of three things that
I did
um it's going great I mean I I see the
returns uh but how much do you have in
total self storage now like 100 million
dollars or something
I think last time I came on it was
15 Properties or so and 20 million
dollars for the storage and
we now have
61 properties uh 1.8 million square feet
of storage we've acquired it for a
hundred and three million dollars we've
raised 41 million dollars from people
like you who invested in both storage
yeah it's been a whirlwind the last two
years have been crazy
[Music]
would you say 100 million dollars worth
of is that that's how much you paid for
it I don't know how much it's worth
I don't either I mean we could we could
guess we could try to guess but look the
real estate market has no Mark to market
right because like Elon Musk you can see
how many shares of Tesla has and the
value of those shares
I have no idea I mean I can make
educated guesses but we sold our
portfolio today
I don't know uh six months ago we might
be able to sell it for 190 million or so
oh that'd be awesome we um I think the
way I met you was so uh you're you know
it's kind of a creepy story years ago I
dated this Polish Girl
and I remember seeing your picture on
Twitter if you're this is so weird your
face reminded me of hers
are you polish
I'm German yeah Huber my my mom is a
ghetto finger so yeah we're very German
I remember seeing your picture and I was
like oh my gosh this guy looks polish
almost and then I was driving
cross-country and I did a Twitter live
or something like that I forget what I
did and you like commented and I just
called you on air or no I called you on
your phone I just put it on speakerphone
and we started talking and that and
that's how we how we how we met I think
right yeah now we know each other quite
well I think we've punched each other in
the face we've uh guarded each other and
fouled each other in basketball we have
uh hung out a couple conferences and and
we talked several times a week so I
appreciate it man I appreciate you too I
I that he told me that he was a
decathlete and I was like yeah
you're not good and then I looked up his
times I was like oh he's better than I
was uh it's and then that's why I like
you even more 400 times I think you ran
47. yeah I opened 47 there's you know
splits are crazy because your coach
wants to tell you that you run really
fast splits to pump you up but he told
me I ran a 46-7 one time split I'd
believe that my so my fastest opens
we're only in the 48 and 49s and my
splits were 47 so you're probably a
second faster than I was but um and did
for those for for the like you went hard
on Twitter when we when like covet
started so there's like we have this
text message group it's me you Sean uh
Austin Reef Nikita beer sahil Bloom Greg
Eisenberg uh I think that's everyone did
I forget yeah you were you were an
addition that came on about six months
or a year after the group started but
yeah it's some good you've added some
good uh great banter to it and like but
the reason the group started was you
guys all went hard on Twitter around the
same time and you like each other's
stuff your thread boys
and then I remember you started doing
that but did of that 100 million dollars
that you've raised or 80 million dollars
that you raised I forget how much how
much has come from 40. you've raised 40.
yeah on Twitter 90 96 of it has come
from Twitter no way is that is that real
yeah mine stop my entire real estate
private Equity company was built on the
back of Twitter yes I had we bought we
built our first self storage facility we
raised 500 Grand my dad took a mortgage
out on our house to do it he didn't tell
me that he did at the time because we
were middle class and I went around to
his friends basically and he helped me
raise the money for that first deal
everybody says you know you're not
self-made and that's mine not self-made
stories that my dad was the first
investor in my first storage building
but
um no then we ran out of money and we
had to buy our second third fourth and
fifth properties with that with our own
cash from our store from our stored
company our moving company so then
you know fast forward to Twitter I'm
tweeting about deals I'm tweeting about
some of our properties and people are
dming me asking to get on our investor
list and
fast forward to today we've raised 40
million bucks from 320 people and we
have 2 000 people on our distribution
list and it's
changed my entire life what's uh 40
million divided by 300 what's the
average check
Ben can help us out maybe I don't have a
calculator on me but yeah 50 Grand
people start we have some investors up
over a million bucks
that's crazy I wish I would have done a
million dollars when I saw like the
checks out yeah
that deal that you're in is going to be
a really good deal we refinanced it in a
really crappy refined environment but
we're going to build some climate
control storage on that property and
that was a deal that was really big and
was uncomfortable man I mean we bought a
nine dollars yeah it was a big deal for
us that was our biggest deal so far is
like hard for us to like get the money
together and and raise the money for it
um nine million bucks and then we bought
another small property after that
another you know portfolio after that
included on the same one our basis is
about 15 million and I got my
spreadsheet up here
yeah total cost total cost but but
you're in for uh uh 20 of 15 right
because you only put or 25 down
yeah exactly right so we we put about 30
down we have you know
12 million in debt
because we refined it we find out some
cash but now it's got a million dollars
of net operating income and it's a you
know
20 20 million dollar plus property which
is great that's crazy yeah I remember
seeing that check well what do you want
to talk about today I want to talk about
all types of stuff dude we have can you
talk about the shepherd thing that
you're doing
yeah so
um that company is a phenomenal company
and and it kind of can kick off our uh
discussion because my goal real estate's
a little bit slow the company's in a
really good spot I still spend a ton of
time saying thumbs up thumbs down to
Deals and thinking strategy and working
on it but
um I have a lot of time and I also have
30 million impressions a month on
Twitter and you know what that's like
when you have a podcast like this and
the distribution that you have
um but yeah my goal right now is to is
to build a portfolio of
ownership chunks and great small
companies you know sweaty startups
um and and Austin our friend Austin Reef
who founded morning Brew he was supposed
to come on today and uh he had like a
last minute board meeting so Axel
Springer thanks a lot the owner of
morning group thanks guys uh but anyway
I was like awesome what should we talk
about and you and me and Austin were the
thing and a group chat and he was like
let's talk about because he knows that I
hate advertising
um and I like make fun of him I used to
make fun of them as like an enemy now I
make fun of him as a friend and
um about how much he makes fun of
everybody Sam not really do I I don't
know it's good it it you just you just
make jokes that are at people's expense
and it's hilarious
and sometimes they're funny and and I
was like Austin what uh what do you want
to talk about he's like let's talk about
non-ways or non-advertising ways to
monetize media followings and
you did it so you did it I don't know
what your net worth would be or what
like the the value of your percentage of
your thing would be but you've done it
to the tune of like 100 million dollars
of real estate that's your
non-advertising way of monetizing your
audience yeah you're also doing it in
like a bunch of sorry go ahead yeah my
equity in that is maybe you know 10 to
20 million yeah so and and so that and
then like you operate this successful
business so it's not like it's just
because of Twitter you know you make
smart decisions beyond that but you are
also doing it a few different ways I'm
actually a customer of your other
business which is a cost sake business I
almost use Shepard which I don't know if
you are a part owner or if you're just
an affiliate for but you're doing it in
a bunch of different ways and I want to
talk about the ways that you're
monetizing in non-addways of your
audience yeah so Shepard is the ideal
Story I mean it was late 2020 November
December I wanted to hire somebody in
the Philippines I met Marshall Haas who
owns the poor Shepherd and I was his
customer I made a deposit for them to
hire somebody and my goal was to get
somebody on the phone in my self storage
facility that could you know press one
to make a payment you're gonna go to
this person and they're just gonna
process the payments for us just some
extra help doing very simple things
I gave them actually they built the job
description they got me three candidates
ready to interview I got on and
interviewed them all in the course of an
hour and I was absolutely blown away and
hired all three of the people I'm like
this what was the rate per hour
five dollars an hour eight hundred
dollars a month to get these people to
come and work for my service company and
they're awesome yeah they were they were
incredible fast forward four hour you
know four months later I had 15 of these
people working inside of my company and
not only were they doing the simple
stuff but they were
answering sales calls they were guiding
the logistics of a customer in a in one
of my facilities looking for a specific
unit they were just able to do exactly
what our American reps do except instead
of paying 60 or 70 grand a year they pay
we pay you know
10 grand a year so it was a game changer
now we have our whole Finance
departments in Columbia Shepard has
helped us find those folks in Columbia
um so the business blew my mind and I
went to Marshall in 2022 or 2021 May
I said hey I want to be an affiliate of
this company like give me a cut of what
I can bring in and I'll do some tweeting
um at that time they were doing about 50
Grand a month and revenue Shepard was
that's 30. that's the net of the net of
payouts to the the workers no that's
like total revenue total revenue for
Shepherd okay as a company as that
business the one that like does the head
hunting and finds the employees for
American companies
um so they were doing you know 50
placements a month or less and they were
growing fast it was a good company and I
started tweeting and pissing off the
woke mob and recommending Port Shepard
for like a 15 cut of Revenue let's say
what those tweets were they're hilarious
I would say like I'm going to weather
this recession for one main reason my my
employees all work for five dollars an
hour in the Philippines and they're
absolutely incredible and then it made
me look like a complete idiot
but the woke mob would just blow these
threads up totally blow them up we're
talking to the tune of three to five
million impressions and so that really
accelerated the growth of Shepard
they're getting a ton of business as it
was they started growing like crazy fast
forward a year later and Shepard had
7xed the size of that company had had
grown by seven seven X and how long one
year one year and it wasn't just because
of me it wasn't just because of me it's
because I started offering folks in
Colombia they started doing a ton of
work
a big part of the puzzle to help it grow
so I went to Marshall and I was like
Marshall this business is way too good
I'm not getting enough money like I want
to own part of support Shepherd and he's
like no way like that's that's
ridiculous you're just you're just an
influencer I was like well man I'm gonna
go start another company
that does exactly this or I could be
a partner of yours and he was and he's
like he's like okay
um you're right like let's make a deal
and we negotiated and I own 15 of
Shepherd and you fast forward to and
what's the deal like you have to keep
referring a certain amount of customers
no the the payoff was canceled I got 15
of profits and he just trusted me that I
was gonna be motivated to continue to do
what I do and now once a month I just
piss off the woke mob on Twitter I send
some newsletter at you know ads and I
kind of sit on the board and do a little
bit of Ops things and recommend but I
mostly just drive those guys and that's
when it comes to that well and wait I
want I want I need you to redeem
yourself really quick because you're
like you're like I'm pissing people off
but the reality is is that like what's
the salary 10 grand a year is what to
them yeah these people me and my one of
my reps were talking the other day and
it's like yeah I bought a house Nick
it's incredible I bought a house in the
Philippines and I'm like what are you
talking about he's like yeah this is my
home it's a three bedroom house that I
bought and uh me and Dan talk all the
time that our that our employees in
Colombia and the Philippines are are
just as wealthy as us they have the same
exact lifestyle as we do because yeah
they get on a bus they commute two hours
and they work for like you know two
dollars an hour over there with with not
the best conditions and then they get to
work for American companies and it
changes their lives so the reality is
that the local mob has no idea what
they're talking about this is incredible
opportunity for them and for us
um and now a lot of people are you know
making that switch and getting employees
over there so all right I I interrupted
you because I wanted you to redeem
yourself but what were you saying about
uh so you fast forward a year now in
another year of promoting and the
business growing and I think 51 of their
their businesses repeat customers who
want to come back forget to get more
um you know help but
it's a multi-seven figure profit
business a year
um I make 50 Grand a month personally
from my 15 ownership and Shepherd
God that's so funny dude you would not
have wanted to go and start a competitor
to them would you that would it sounds
hard it sounds like a hard business to
operate it's really hard they got 150
employees I was mostly bluffing I mean
it's a super hard business to start they
have a ton of really good talent and a
ton of like sales reps and like the way
that they do business is really
difficult they got to go and recruit and
interview all these people over there
and vet them and grade their English and
like get all these people these
employees put to put in front of these
business owners so yeah
um it was and Marshall's a pretty good
entrepreneur I like Marshall a lot I
mean he's done like eight different
companies and a few of them very very
well very good entrepreneur so yeah
that's hilarious I can't believe you you
worked that out I mean I think that's a
good deal I've had so I've had a few
people so I there's this guy who did
this guy Diego
um what's his website is it like short Z
I think it's like like short clips I'll
have to find it but anyway he uh this
dude dm'd me yeah I think he's
is he Cuban or he's not from America I
forget what he is but he uh
he DMS me and I get these DMS all the
time
so they're like I'm gonna make videos
for you you get those with like I wanna
I'm like dude shut up okay we have three
a day that people want to write my
newsletter for me yeah it's like stuff
like that all the time and nine out of
ten of them they're just like really bad
they're not good uh at what they do and
this guy just kept dming me and I was
like
screw it fine
like just make clips for me send me 10
of them like I just said something
stupid or something like that just to
like get them off my back any like
within before the night was over he sent
me like 10 and they were pretty good
and uh I was like uh all right well I
don't want to post these I'm gonna make
you post them for me I'm gonna give you
my Instagram password
um send me a picture of your driver's
license your social security card and he
told me at one point he lived with his
girlfriend some of your girlfriend's
driver's license too
and he
sends me a picture of all of them but I
go great I know a lot about you I'm
gonna I'm gonna you know we're gonna
have an issue if you screw me here's my
password to my Instagram
[Laughter]
make it work
and he does and he kills it and I go
from like a thousand followers to like
10 000 followers in a week and then like
up now to fifty thousand he kills how
much do you pay him
so get this so I was like all right
you're right you're awesome but here's
the deal
you're gonna do this for me for free for
a long time and in exchange I'm gonna
tell all of my friends about you and uh
I'm eventually once you prove it to my
friends I'm gonna tweet out that I think
you're great
um and he said great and so within a
month of him messaging me we got him up
to like 20 grand a month or something
like that I forget like a really good
wage
um and he's like has his thriving
business and then I tweet him out and we
send tons of customers to him and so I
also do the same thing where I take a
small percentage of the profits and I'm
loving this but I would rather have the
profits rather than equity in the
business but really I think you mean
like a cut a cut of Revenue you'd have a
revenue rather have a revenue share than
Equity slice
sent me a text yesterday and said Nick
what's your three biggest regrets in
life and one of them he asked you that
question what a weird question to ask he
works on he works on this dumbass
content online who knows what he's going
to Tweet about why is he asking you that
okay go ahead one of them was not going
to Marshall a year earlier and getting
Equity instead of freaking a cut of
profits
yeah uh
yeah I I just don't know if a clip
agency is ever going to sell yeah I love
agency I love agency businesses and I I
don't want to like give advice to people
all the time do you know what I mean I
think it's different when you're with
Marshall because Marshall is like a very
proven entrepreneur who has a couple
exits unders underspelled but like
sometimes he doesn't want to listen yeah
they don't need or want me to get
involved in their operations yeah yeah
I'm like dude I don't want to like uh I
don't want to guide you I just want to
send you customers and um I like I
sometimes I prefer transactional is what
I mean
um yeah so I love leaning in I love
leaning into the Ops my business partner
is an operational Mastermind and you
know yeah I have three other companies
that I'm working on launching right now
on a very same
very similar trajectory as support
Shepherd
by the way Diego's company is called
short it's like a short clip and then zy
dot Co short Z dot Co so short and then
zy.com yeah man you should own you
should own 25 of his company
um yeah I don't know maybe maybe I will
end up regretting that but I'm I'm happy
with the deal yeah but we uh and so uh
what were the other two regrets oh
um
I don't know let me look
I think it was
um go ahead and get married a little
earlier and have kids a little earlier
even though I did it when I was almost
30.
um and then you aren't married until
you're 30 or first kid I got married
when I was 27 I had my first kid at 29
and I kind of if that was three years
earlier I would have been just as happy
but in general how many so many people I
talked to say they wish they would have
had their kids earlier by the way and
I'm shocked that people say that are you
are you excited to be a dad at some
point I know you and Sarah started to
talk about it are you what do you what
do you think about how do you think
that's going to change your life I'm
pumped I'm so pumped I I think that
um a I agree I wish I would have done it
earlier
um and I am so pumped I think it's gonna
be life-changing I think I was talking
to Sarah about this last night I was
like
so we've achieved a lot of like
interesting things at a relatively young
age like professionally like we're known
in our field and like we have some
respect amongst some peers financially
like we've achieved some things
um like and then we were like
parents say like well you're never ready
and I was thinking last night I'm like
dude I'm totally ready like what else do
I need to do this is like it feels like
the next step so I'm incredibly ready
and I don't really care about this but I
actually think it's going to Turbo
Charge my career
um I think that like it's gonna make you
feel like amped up like before it was I
was earning
so I don't know why I was earning I was
trying to make money for ego egotistical
reasons and then after that I was like
now I'm in the place where I make money
because I do [__] that's fun and because
of my fun hobbies often the outcome is
income I pick and choose different
things now I think it's gonna feel like
I want something for my children I want
to impress them
um I want to show them how to work hard
I think that there's going to be like a
little bit of that and it's also going
to be like I don't want to spend all of
my time uh after like 6 p.m working and
so I have to pick and choose my battles
and I think that's gonna actually Force
focus and the outcome will be better
financially am I wrong I think you are
right on the money with your two things
there's two more
number one is that you are going to get
so much more emotionally mature
when you have kids
at least for me I was highs lows I would
it just it just puts stress in relative
form when you know you have a human that
you have to care for and the stress
level of when that human is sick or when
when they scream or when they cry or
when they hurt themselves when they
suffer
that puts it all in perspective so you
just get like better at dealing with
stress the second thing is like I got
more focused I was able to get more work
done when I couldn't travel the world I
couldn't go play golf all the time I
couldn't just get on a plane and go be
spontaneous and go spend two weeks in
Europe
so instead
I would spend really good quality time
with my family in my house and then pop
to my computer to you know Tinker inside
of my business and make my business
better I was just more I don't know does
that make sense yeah it totally makes
sense and I'm pumped we have three kids
now yeah five five three and nine months
yeah man I'm I'm pumped for it and I I
think the I don't care about this but I
think the outcome will be a better
career because of children that's that
that's my prediction I think you're
right
I want to talk about the cost seg
business because that thing so that
seems like it's going even better than
um
support Shepherd so uh I'm a customer I
used it I got it for free though so I I
am a customer and I uh you did a video
so cost tag is we have Engineers who go
in and they break out the different
parts of a commercial property or an
income property a piece of real estate
and then they give you a schedule of
which you can depreciate that to the IRS
meaning like because normally is what 27
years it's normally 27 years straight
line depreciation
they take it so that oh the windows
those are only a five-year life you know
the Landscaping outside that only has a
five-year life then you got all these
ground improvements that we're going to
make and all these other things that can
be accelerated a little faster so and
there's something called bonus
depreciation we're going away in the
weeds you don't need to know that but
basically our Engineers come in the
building they draw a picture of the
property they split it out into
different values and they give you a
document that you can go to the IRS to
get way more depreciation and save money
you're one so I haven't gotten my I
haven't gotten my report yet though but
let's just make believe on a million
dollar property that what's a million
divided by 27 is what yeah 27
000 is it 27
000 a year yeah okay and depreciation
duh uh 2.2 maybe something like that and
then on um with this it would be what
like 200 Grand in year one yeah on a
self storage facilities anywhere from 20
to 30 percent year one depreciation
um an industrial property might be 10 to
20 and RV park might be 60 70 it just
depends on how many ground how much
ground improvements you've done like
work to the outside of the property
Landscaping you know when
do I pay that tax back if I sell the
property before 27 years
um yeah it's called recapture so if you
don't plan to hold the property for a
while then you need to keep some money
because your basis drops basically your
taxable basis drops by the amount that
you'd appreciate so that Gap is called
recapture and you pay that at the
recapture rate stuff like that so yeah
and where's my team doing this
um we have
my friend Mitchell Baldridge who you
know his wife Mel um they are my
partners my business partner Dan is
minority owner as well
um I own 45 of Ari kosseg and I mean
Mitchell Mitchell had done
100 plus of these before we started this
company and he'd never really thought
about hey uh we can we can find some
engineers and do this stuff really well
um we've created a Twitter account Ari
kosteg we got really competitive pricing
because instead of me flying somebody to
your property in Texas we did a FaceTime
you facetimed with one of our guys and
he walked around took some screenshots
what was that like my property manager
did it and I was out there with her and
I think
she was on her phone I wish she was on
her phone and she said the guy sounded
Italian are they in Italy or something
they're all over yeah we have some
people in Miami
um Florida's pretty popular Colombia
Philippines we've hired uh seven people
from support through support Shepherd
for this company
um it's which is another funny part
about it but yeah we have 23 23
employees uh Mitchell's wife Mel who
spent eight years at KPMG or uh yeah
yeah one of the big one of the big
consulting firms she was a Management
Consultant she's the CEO of the company
and yeah we're nine months old and we
did 250 000 of Revenue last month
dude that's crazy and I remember like so
uh Jen my PM it took her like 20 or 30
minutes until my property's big it's
like 20 acres but there's like a 4 000
square foot house and then
um like a barn that has a gym it's this
for an Airbnb I have and she like spent
maybe 20 minutes walking around and he
was like what's that thing and they're
like oh that's like our water purifying
system and he's like all right cool let
me see that all right cool uh show me
all the windows yeah they look like okay
what can we depreciate faster and
they're like show me this show me that
yeah yeah and he and she was like we
have two garage doors here and he was
like all right cool let me see that
garage door uh I forget what else it was
but uh like like she was just walking
around and he like had a checklist but
then also he would see stuff and like
ask like wait let me see that uh water
filtration system or like uh you know
this my properties out in the country so
we have like a a well or something and I
think she was like let me see the well
like like you like wanted to see all
this stuff and I haven't gotten the
report yet I think we just get it did it
like 10 or seven days ago yeah
and there's one other
company in the space that's doing it
that I almost went with it was called
the Madison spec is yep yeah they'll fly
somebody out to your property and
they'll charge you twice as much to do a
cost effect because they gotta get
somebody out there so it's a different
scenario when I read about this uh Mark
Jenny so we have this friend named Mark
Jenny who talked about the party he's a
badass yeah he's badass he has like I
don't know his portfolio is like mid
eight figures of Airbnb the bar stool
guys rented one of his houses for Super
Bowl week dude I saw the so the Barstool
guys are in Arizona I think for yeah and
I saw like the mini Putt-Putt course in
basketball and I was like I bet this is
Marx and then you or someone else told
us that it was Marx and he uh I was he's
inspired me to get into airbnbs I was
like Mark what should I read and he like
sent me some book and he told and that's
what I learned about accelerated
depreciation and I started Googling how
to how to do it and I only found a
couple firms doing it so I thought this
was going to be like a niche business I
didn't think it was gonna be like a big
business what how big do you think this
is gonna get
my prediction and again I I try not to
make predictions because then I just set
expectations and end up getting you know
stressed because of expectations and
stress and that stuff but yeah I think
we'll do three to five million of
Revenue over the next 12 months and I
think about I think it'll become a it'll
become over the next five years a 10 to
15 million dollar a year Revenue
business I don't I mean you don't have
to set expectations but I will but I
feel like that is under shooting it I
think it could be potentially bigger I
don't know how big the market is but I
bet you there's just so many other
services that you can begin to offer
depending on how hard you want to work
yeah we're launching so that's
recast.com we're launching tax credit
hunter.com as well to do ERC credits and
employee retention credits same
leadership group Mitchell Mitchell and
Mel
um that's when you didn't if you didn't
lay off employees during covid and you
own a small business you can get
um into employee retention tax credits
back from the IRS and you need Metro you
need Michelin to really talk about that
stuff I can't
um guide but basically if you didn't
fire your employees when covet hit and
you kept them on the government is
offering massive tax credits to your
business and very few entrepreneurs know
it they expire in 2025 and yeah it's
it's it's significant we're talking the
guys that we know who are running
companies with 150 employees are looking
at
100 to a million dollars in tax credits
100 000 million there's a company called
Main Street Main Street they do the
exact same thing I think Sean either
invested or knows the guy who founded it
named Doug and they were an Advertiser
with the hustle they're a good company
but what they did was how much money did
they raise I think they raised they did
the exact same thing you're saying they
probably had like a Tech play to it I
don't remember exactly but they're still
around but I think they raised like two
or three hundred million dollars like a
I forget the exact number but like a
huge amount and I think they just
recently laid off a ton of people not
because the business stinks but I think
they just like raised a ton of money and
hired a ton of people
um but I do think that that's proof that
this if I'm in your position and I'm
like oh well you guys have just
validated the idea and concept we're not
going to raise money because we don't
want to screw up our cap table but I bet
we can do this because we already have a
little bit of money we already have an
audience maybe we won't grow as fast but
we'll own the whole thing and do it our
way and I think yeah the audience is the
key I mean the the re Costa Twitter
account which I I run in Mitchell runs
uh it's got 13 over 13 000 followers
already
no [__] what are you Tweeting on there
that make people follow it
um just all about Costa all about Real
Estate Investors client examples
Anonymous client examples about how much
money we save clients
um it blows people's mind when they
realize that Real Estate Investors you
can make
I mean I'm an example of this you can
make two three million dollars a year
from operating companies and if you're a
real estate professional and you buy
property each year and you cost seg them
and appreciate them you can have zero
tax liability zero
yeah but becoming a real estate
professional is a pain in the butt I try
to do it I try to do it and I I was like
there's no way I can justify like
basically to if I remember correctly to
become a real estate professional you
have to uh I forget exactly 700 hours
you have to spend you have to be the
person who spends the most time in the
business yeah there's you need a good
CPA to really like log your time and
create a rock solid case and then you
also have to I think a certain I think
of the majority of your income has to
come from Real Estate if I remember
correctly or you can't is there
something where like the where is it
like you're outside your all your
revenue streams can't add up to be more
than your uh than your uh real estate
income is it something like that I
thought that there was something where
like you can't make too much money well
maybe I'm wrong but I remember the 700
thing I was like there's no way I can
qualify I think you can get some Advent
I think you can get some I don't want to
talk out of my ass here I don't remember
exactly but I think if you do 360 hours
you can you can get some uh uh
short-term rentals short-term rentals
there's a loophole in it right now we're
doing a ton of cost things on people who
have short-term rentals because they
don't have to be a real estate
professional they just have to spend
more time on that rental property than
anybody else and there's some threads
that Mitchell Baldridge has and if you
search it if you search short-term
rental on the re costume account you can
read the thread but yeah it's a there's
a loophole around uh short-term rentals
well that's sick dude I think that
potentially those businesses can be
bigger than like your storage thing but
that's just because that's what I know
is like internet businesses but I think
that actually could be pretty massive
right I think I I'm very bullish on what
could happen I'm excited yeah and then
I'm also buying a I'm buying and
rebranding a Property and Casualty
Insurance company they provide
property insurance like if you have a
commercial piece of property a self
storage facility or a multi-family unit
you need to get property insurance on
that in case there's a tornado or a fire
or somebody slips and Falls outside yeah
I mean I have it at my Airbnb I think
yeah I think it's expensive I'm pretty
sure I pay five or six thousand a year
does that sound right yeah that sounds
right we pay over 400 000 or over 350
000 annually to ensure our self storage
portfolio but it's also a pain to work
with these insurance companies like the
brokerages operate like it's 1950 you
have to prove yeah I don't have like a
login I think I just have like a PDF
that like they sent me and then they
sent me more questions that said like
hey did you ever fix this handrail or
something like that yeah and uh anyway
like it's pretty Antiquated it's my
business partner we were working with a
top 10 firm in the country brokerage
firm top ten this is one of the biggest
companies and my business partner Dan
had to go into that business and build a
system for them to quickly get us quotes
on properties and to bind our coverage
we can't pay online things move slow as
hell nobody responds to us so yeah we're
buying an insurance company in Kansas
City we're rebranding it as Titan risk
titanrisk.com is the shout out and we're
gonna spin up a Property and Casualty
Insurance Company on the back of again
the
the the following uh your website's down
so you gotta is it titanrisk.com you
said yeah all right yeah it'll be up
it'll be up by tomorrow hopefully all
right good I I don't know I think this
episode might go live tomorrow so you
gotta get it up by then on Thursday what
uh what did you pay for that
um the guy was doing he he we found a
guy who had a really good contract base
with carriers because that's the key
like everybody goes the same carriers
but you have to have contracts with
those really good carriers
um we found a guy in Kansas City who had
that and he was I think he's doing
million million and a half of Revenue
inside of a shop he's the producer he
has four back office we're gonna hire
folks through Shepard and some Americans
as well
um account admins and we're gonna lean
on his shop at the beginning and kind of
spin up a secondary brand so
so if I come on if I come on in six
months I'd give you I'd be able to share
a ton because this is in its infancy but
I'm more excited about this business
than I am about
um
Ari Costa again and uh type tax tax
credit Hunter
our software is the worst have you heard
of HubSpot see most trms are a cobble
together mess but HubSpot is easy to
adopt and actually looks gorgeous I
think I love our new CRM our software is
the best HubSpot grow better
I want to ask you about the fourth one
but for the first three did you put up
any capital for any of them yeah we
funded a checking account
um
for Ari Costa we put 50 Grand in there
and then the two months later you know
we were making distributions that's
nothing
right that's not that enough and dude
that's crazy to me the great thing about
hiring an employee even if you hire a
really good engineer for a hundred
thousand dollars
you're only paying them 8 300 a month do
you have Engineers for these companies
yeah you need we have civil engineers
inside of our Acosta so yeah it's this
is this stuff's not easy right Mel
Baldridge is a badass like she's
managing 23 people we're doing a ton of
volume of sales doing all these CAD
drawings breaking down these properties
Marshall's team is really badass like
none of these companies are Easy by any
means who's building the system so like
and not civil engineers but I mean like
uh web
yeah we're using air table as a CRM
um we have a lot of out of the pocket
Tech but yeah we're getting some web
work done as well and I'm starting a a
web a web landing page front-end
development company as well called
webron.com but that's with another guy
that's going to be spun up in the next
month so yeah I mean it's getting it's
getting fun I want to ask you about this
last one and then uh I want to ask you
more questions about all this stuff I'm
gonna write my questions down because I
don't want to interrupt you what's this
pest thing oh The Pest Control business
um I have an LP a good friend of mine
who owns Six branches of a pest control
company
and he needs to he needs Capital to go
buy additional properties and he's got
some Capital but not you know five or
ten million dollars and I said
properties I meant additional companies
to latch on to his to his business but
um I might do a deal with him where I
sit on the board and I advise
operationally I help them hire overseas
Talent through support Shepard and
Implement them inside the company and
then uh raise the money from my Real
Estate Investors to buy the business
but that's in its infancy as well I need
more time to to really talk on that so
um about
between two and six months ago Sean and
I on this pod talked about a few things
I told him
I was like basically like on Instagram
you have like Rihanna and the
Kardashians and then there's like
thousands and thousands of more but
those two those the the Kardashians and
Rihanna are like two prominent examples
of people who have built hundreds of
millions or billions of dollars worth of
uh net worth via Instagram
on YouTube we have Mr bees he's like the
common he's the one everyone talks about
um and then you know there's way more uh
of people who have built like there's
the lady who started Ipsy I think it's
called the makeup brand there's just
tons of them on Facebook you could say
that like BuzzFeed and like uh um a
bunch of other people like you know
built multi-billion dollar businesses on
the backs of Facebook now
there hasn't really been one who's done
it on Twitter
the and Snapchat same thing we can think
of a few more examples the reason
Twitter maybe it hasn't worked is
because I think people haven't taken it
seriously and also there's only like 350
million people on it as opposed to
Instagram there's like what billions
but I think that's changing and what we
haven't seen yet is someone who has
built like the the equivalent of the
Kardashians uh on Twitter except instead
of selling makeup I think they're going
to be selling B2B or professional
whatever that is considered you know B2B
services or uh something where it's like
a higher end person not a young woman
buying like 12 makeup and
um
we haven't seen that yet and then Sean
was like yeah and then we have like the
guy Mafia so you have people like the
strip mall it's like these Anonymous
accounts like the strip mall guy who I
know who he is I'm friends with him and
he is a large business and I I don't
know what it what has come from Twitter
but he has large business and then
there's like five or six other guys
there's like the used car salesperson
guy and he's like potentially going to
build a large business and like it's
very predictable luxury watch guys is
selling shitloads of watches on Twitter
yeah I almost bought a Rolex from he
like had these datejust that I wanted
no one has done this to the extent of
like hundreds of millions I guess you
kind of almost have already but no one
has done this to the extent that I think
possible you might be one of the first
or at least one of the people that I
know closely who might be one of these
early people to build a multi-hundred
million or even a billion dollar Fortune
mostly because of your audience on
Twitter do you think that's that's uh uh
accurate I think these companies are so
in so in their infancy and it's really
easy to get to 250 Grand of Revenue but
ask guys like Andrew Wilkinson how hard
it is to go from 250
000 a month to you know 250 million
dollars a year in Revenue like those
types of jumps is on another level right
I don't know if I have what it takes to
do things like that
but you give it 10 or 15 years to mature
I don't know I think what Austin Reef
does at morning Brew like managing these
bigger companies is just a different
skill set it's different like but you're
not doing it
but I'd have to become a billionaire
wouldn't I
I don't know because dude it's kind of
like you're like the Ryan Reynolds of
Twitter a little bit you know what I
mean like he's got mint mobile he has
the soccer team that he partakes in he's
got uh I don't the the alcohol drink
that he has uh I think he has a few more
I I mean that guy's not operating those
companies Conor McGregor's not operating
the whiskey thing but like and I can't
operate frankly I can't operate my
companies either I'm focused on my real
estate and everything else yeah and so
my point being is if you're just if you
have 10 to 20 or 30 percent of a handful
of things
one of them could hit there's this guy
named Felix Dennis have you ever read uh
this awesome book called How to get rich
I love that book yeah I love that book I
recommend that book to everyone it's
horribly titled but it's the best book
I've ever you should have equity in that
book Sam
dude I I whenever we mention in the Pod
well notice the next day it goes up the
charts like a ton and uh well he's dead
now but he he built like a publishing
Empire that was like it made him a lot
of money but the bulk of his wealth was
he owned 10 or 20 of this thing called
micro Warehouse which went public for
multi-billions and he made many many
hundreds of millions from it and he had
the same thing where he was like look I
own the magazines that I'm gonna promote
you guys in there for free and I'm also
going to be like an advisor but I'm
going to be considered a co-founder and
this was my idea and I hired you guys
but he didn't manage the company he met
with the with the other Founders a lot
and he gave it his uh opinion but he
wasn't like running the data day thing I
don't see why you you couldn't do that
with a few more things I think the
you know the power of
blowing up a brand is one thing the
power of spotting and reading and hiring
and delegating to really good operators
is something is another thing as well
that's underrated and something that I
think that I'm good at finding people
who really think about business the
right way and to build these companies I
can't operate them I'm an investor I'm
an advisor and I pump their stuff on
Twitter and I'm a customer and I you
know help but you gotta find somebody
who really is really good at running a
company and that's where I wish I I made
a joke on Twitter that offended a couple
of my good friends a couple days ago
that said like I need to do more Angel
Investing so that I can invest in these
companies I can see how these Founders
think about business and how they make
decisions and how they write their
updates and how they fight through and I
can get a look into their brain and I
can spot The Killers right I can find
those those guys that are just really
good at business and then I can pull
them aside when they give up and I made
a a statement like the hell you know
when they want to leave the hellscape
that is Venture Capital that's not true
um it was it was uh it was just not cool
for me to say that about my buddies who
had so much value to the world in that
space but anyway and you're joking
I was I was half joking half being
serious because I want to pull these
people away and and basically found and
start and buy businesses that I think
they could come in and run great
businesses that are ran like crap and
just accelerate their growth and make
them better
dude Austin reef is an amazing operator
and
um I remember when I first met him I was
probably 28 or 29 or 30 and he's younger
than me he's four years younger than me
and I was like you're the first person
you're one of the very few people who's
like my peer but younger than me who
I'm I'm a little intimidated by I'm like
you you I I I remember telling him I was
like dude I'm a lot better than you had
a few things you are so much better than
me at a few other things and I wish I
was looking for the way that he
listening to the way that he thinks
about business problems and the way that
he talks through them and the way that
he paints a story in a clear and concise
way when you're asking him about his
business is that's what I'm talking
about that's the 10xer Austin is the 10x
series 100x totally he's on another
level but like when you're around a lot
of these people and you talk to them you
start asking questions and hearing the
way they think about business you can do
it too like you can just tell you can
tell when somebody's different when
somebody's really got it
you know what I mean he's the best but I
would also say like Andrew Wilkinson's a
great friend of mine I don't know what
his Empire's worth but in the 500 to a
billion range depending on public
markets he uh when I talked to him
I don't feel like
I'm like Andrew I don't feel you're out
of my league you've just been doing it
for longer and you are really creative
and you were the first person you were
you were Bolder and smarter than than me
to like believe that this could actually
become a thing and you did the thing and
then you did it for years and years and
you didn't give up and you never bowed
down you always did it your way but in
terms of like your vision and my vision
you know my vision now that I see you
could do it I'm like I don't think your
ball I think we're in the same ballpark
of like intellect
um and so that's why when I see him I'm
like dude you're inspiring to me because
I kind of feel like we're almost the
same although the results are not the
same and I find that to be very
inspirational and that's kind of the
same for you maybe like you look at a
guy like him and be like oh man Andrew
is my idol yeah I mean that man
understands leverage and delegation
unlike anybody that I've ever met right
he can find somebody he can he can his
his brain is so good at analyzing the
pros and the cons of making a bet he
does business like a poker player right
when the odds are in his favor he's
gonna go big and he's just proven that
he he can make those bets better than
anybody else he'd find those excellent
operators and I think he's an undercover
killer too I mean I know that he comes
off really humble but the dude is I
think he's a killer too he's a killer
and anyone who's that successful is not
not a killer uh yeah you're right he and
he does a good job because he's like is
a I always tease him I'm like dude
you're always dressed so nice when you
have slick back hair like you like have
this like designer like uh look to you
but like you're like quit acting like
you're like uh not a killer because you
definitely are he's got it why what do
you what do you do with your bunny do
you what do you invest in
um well real estate I'm not that liquid
right I haven't sold a company I haven't
sold any properties so I personally
guarantee you know 50 million dollars
plus of debt and I only have 3.6 million
dollars liquid so I'd be foolish to
start spending that on houses cars and
boats right so
um I keep a lot of cash about a million
in cash I keep another another two and a
half million in public equities that I
can create are you Trading
buy stocks and hold them for a long time
I'm way too dumb to try to guess what's
going to happen inside of them but you
didn't used to be that way
um I bought some dumb we talked about
our friend Austin Reef I bought some
dumb stocks
that I then sold six months later for a
big loss absolutely but I'm not trying
to day trade in time markets awesome
tell us all that that Zillow was like
the buy he was like
but I it was a fair argument but we
bought it at 150 bucks it went up to 200
and I was getting texts from Austin that
the that you know let's let's go this is
incredible now it's 30 bucks or
something
um but no I mean Google and Facebook and
Microsoft and Apple all the best
companies in the world all got 50
percent
cheaper so I bought a lot of those and
I'm gonna hold them for five years and
I'm sure that I'll do fine
what's motivating you right now I just
think it's fun I mean the building the
building is really fun is that what you
I mean I want to talk about you now too
Sam because you're
you're not over here how many years post
exit are you four years out no dude two
two two years okay never mind
um
yeah I mean you build something you sell
something you have that event and then
when it's over you're like
oh [__] I kind of I love I love building
I love tinkering I love entrepreneurship
and business I needed
so I gave myself one year to I basically
wrote the rules where I was like I'm
gonna read anything that interests me
whether that's so I read a lot of
fiction and I read I don't read business
books anymore
um and then I also said I'm just gonna
search I'm just gonna search so I'm just
gonna plot and search and just whatever
interest me I'm just gonna pursue it you
know I was like I was like I'm just
gonna a dog on a walk file on my nose
and I'm not gonna like feel guilty about
that and I noticed that after about six
months I was ready to roll again I made
some mistake I made some irreversible
decisions at my company like some
culture decisions basically when I
started the company I was 25 and then
when I about sold it I was about 30 and
like I was a different person and I'm
more solid on who I am now so I would
have different values when I start in my
next things but anyway I made some
mistakes so I basically kind of had to
sell the company or in order to like get
out and so I was pumped about it
but at the same time I was like I wish I
was wealth I wish I was I wasn't wealthy
when I started a business I had nothing
I was like I wish I was wealthy so I
didn't have to sell this to get
liquidity because I would have liked to
have owned it forever but I was very
very very happy to get that time to
relax and to seek and then after about
six months I was like dude I need action
I need to gamble I felt I remember
watching a James Bond movie and I'm like
should I become a cop like I need to go
out and like get into trouble like I
need to experience like it's the real
certainty I think it's like it's the
it's making a decision where you don't
know what the answer is going to be
and then waiting and seeing what happens
that is just incredibly addicting about
entrepreneurship dude I just like like
being a [__] with my friends I love
our group chat like when it gets spicy I
like think about it all the time like
it's so funny and I'm like I gotta go do
something now to one-up the the guys
here and that's how I feel so like my my
best the best time I have that I love
the best when it comes to work is when
I'm with like my partner Joe or someone
like that and we're like we can't pull
this off can we ah [__] let's go try it
like that that adrenaline that's like my
version of like James Bond when I'm
watching him like having like a car
chase I'm like dude let's this is our
this is our nerdy version of a card
Chase I need that thrill and it just so
happens that the outcome typically is
money and so that's what I'm motivated
by is like the thrill um I don't give a
[__] about Legacy when people talk about
Legacy I'm like I don't give a [__] dude
I'm gonna I'm like imagine the feeling
that you had when you before you were
born that's what I think I'm gonna have
when I'm dead why do I care what people
think about me you know I want to like
leave something to my children because I
love them but like I don't give a [__]
about what everyone else thinks I don't
care about Legacy I just want to have
fun and like have excitement in the
moment and that's what I'm motivated by
yeah I'm making these making these
business deals and these business
decisions and these in these calculated
bets we'll call them like been with you
and and all these things I'm working on
there just calculated bets and when you
when you put the money in you just never
know what's gonna happen you never know
what's gonna happen when you try to sell
it when you start to get customers when
you start to solve problems and it's
it's addicting for sure by the way well
we can keep this on but producer Ben we
have to bleep out the name of what he
just said I haven't announced that yet
but can we talk about it can we yeah
yeah we can't say what it is but we can
we can we can mention I have a thing
that I'm going to be announcing in a
month
Nick just said the name of it we got to
bleep that out I'll be announcing it in
one month I've been doing it low-key for
two reasons one I wanted to prove that I
can do it without my audience
um and two I wanted to make sure that it
worked and was life-changing It's a
Wonderful product before I like get like
an influx but I'm gonna announce that in
a month
um what else we want to talk about
anything else I mean I mean I've been
thinking a little bit about like what
holds people back and
anxiety and the decision making that
like you have anxiety no I just mean
like the uncertainty like the the fear
of failure like it's it's in everybody
not not that I guess anxiety is a is a
bad term more like insecurity right I
have insecurity and the and it holds me
back from making big decisions
and the problem with it is is the more
insecure you are the less decisions you
make and decision making is like
something that you have to practice to
get really good at if you don't make
decisions with a lot on the line you
have to you're never going to get better
at it ever going to get better at it so
then you have unmade decisions and that
equals stress because stress is a
decision that hasn't yet been made and
it just cycles and snowballs so people
who are they have insecurity they have
anxiety around making decisions
then they get stressed out because they
have these decisions and it's just a big
compounding snowball of
of like it just holds people back from
kicking so much ass like every High
performer that I know they make a ton of
decisions they make some of them wrong
they lose some money like there's
downside of course but they just make
them and make them and make them and
they make them quick and they get better
at it and better at it and better at it
and that's when The Leverage kicks in
and they can just build and grow a Build
and Grow my parents when I was a younger
kid I would like sell CDs or like sell
used stuff on eBay and I remember making
mistakes and they're like oh that's all
right you can't get a hit unless you're
in the game and uh I was there like uh
you're swinging your Miss but you know
you gotta you gotta swing to get the hit
and you can't get hit unless you're in
the game I remember hearing that and
that like changed my life and so now
whenever I screw up I'm like ah whatever
like you know a 300 batting average in
baseball is great so I'm like that's all
I need like that and business is fine in
fact in business you actually need less
if you try 100 times and one thing works
it makes up for all the 99 things
um but that's what I always tell people
I'm like dude you gotta you gotta you
can't get a hit unless you're in the
game I've been asking High performers
this because now I have a five-year-old
I'm thinking about what I can do for my
kids to help them
just get better at making decisions and
get you know more a more solid
foundation a more solid foundation in
the event of insecurity did your parents
just like
let you struggle a little bit like
that's something that I found is very
common among entrepreneurs and
successful people because so many
parents nowadays they really mess up
because they like shelter their kids
from all decision making they like make
the decisions for the kids they like
they they keep them from getting in any
pain at all they're going to keep them
from having to deal with the uncomfort
of pain they're gonna put them in a
bubble and I look back on my parents and
my my parents would like
they would make me make the little
decisions when I was a kid so that I got
better at making the decisions and then
when they were bigger I wasn't
overwhelmed with fear and insecurity I
was always skateboarding and
rollerblading and going to skate parks
and I remember I had a unicycle I would
and I would try to write it downstairs
and they were like
I was crazy I was like do all this crazy
stuff I remember when I was in fourth
grade I could ride a unicycle and juggle
and I would do all this crazy like
skateboarding [__] and they would be
like uh hey let's go to the skate park
uh but the only rules they had was you
have to wear a helmet they go as long as
you wear a helmet we don't care and so I
was in and out of the hospital broken
broken broken fingers uh stitches on my
eye broke my arm broke my collarbone
I've had a lot of broken bones and they
were I always say my parents
they once I uh left school I wasn't
financially uh like they didn't they've
never like helped me with the business
or anything but they supported me up
until then and
so I had that but they were emotionally
supportive so I remember when I left
school and moved up to San Francisco and
told them I was going to join this thing
called Airbnb
they were like
this sounds like a multi-level marketing
thing like is this and I was like no
guys like this like I think it's legit
like at the time I was like two or three
hundred people worked there it's legit
and they're like you're gonna leave
school to go do this and I was like yeah
it's legit and they're like that sounds
horrible but uh you know we'll see you
Saturday we'll come down there and help
you move out and so like they did things
like that that were like very
emotionally supportive and so and that
was like huge and so a lot of my friends
who don't take risks oftentimes their
parents were quite neurotic and they
instead of saying um why uh
instead of saying like of course this
can work they would default to saying
like well this will never work because
of this this and this or like you can't
go study abroad like Mexico is dangerous
haven't you seen that there's like
shootings or uh you know like people get
sick when they uh do this and that like
I remember like that was usually the
default versus like screw it we'll we'll
handle it when we get there yeah putting
your kids in a bubble and now that I
have a five-year-old like it sucks to
watch him struggle and I have a bunch of
employees and it sucks to watch I I
don't know there's there's a lot of
similarities between like raising your
kid get hurt though like let's say your
kids riding a bike and he's wearing a
helmet and you're like dude he's 100
about to knock his teeth out
um if he's about to hurt himself bad and
I'm gonna go to the emergency room
obviously I'm gonna run and try to catch
him but if he's over on the other side
of the cul-de-stack a knee it's a curb
and he falls down and he starts
screaming
I'm not gonna Sprint over there and pick
him up and coddle him does that make
sense like I'm gonna yeah I'm gonna let
him I'm gonna let him figure that crap
out but I just think it bleeds over into
everything like if you if an employee
walks into your office and that they
have a problem and you just say get out
of my way I'm going to solve that
problem then that enables that enables
them to a it doesn't let them learn how
to solve problems on their own and be it
enables them to bring you more and more
problems and just be completely unable
to like get [__] done without you as a
boss
um do you uh Ben just texted me and he
wanted he wanted me to ask you you have
all three boys right
I have a five-year-old boy
three-year-old boy two uh all right ten
month old girl
are you gonna raise her the same way I
would imagine yes right
oh man I don't know I don't know if I
will
yeah
if I have a daughter I mean this is my
I'm hypothetical you're living it but I
think I would definitely you gotta do it
the same way right yeah oh yeah I'm
gonna I'm gonna raise strong secure
daughter for sure like hey I'm going to
show her that I'm going to treat her
mother with a ton of respect and that
her mother should never take [__] from
me just because I'm a man right that's
that's something like you [__] women
in the long run if you like enable or
like lead them to be insecure so I'm
gonna try to raise like a really strong
confident secure
girl who can yeah knows how to struggle
with grace absolutely so when she falls
down on her bike not gonna run over
there either I guess
well good dude I'm happy you came on I
like talking to you
um by the way we do this thing on on our
YouTube channel I'm gonna do it now I'm
supposed to do it earlier on we talk
about the gentleman's agreement have you
heard me say this I have not damn you're
catching me I'm totally blind so we
we've been growing our YouTube
subscribers at I think last month we
grew by twenty thousand
and the pitch was this which I stole it
from this guy named Jesse on fire so I'm
not gonna act like I came up with it but
it was uh we guilted people a little bit
we said hey hold on hold on I normally
say this in the beginning I forgot to do
today go hold on unlike everything else
on YouTube our content is not for free
we actually work for you and the way
that you pay us back it's kind of like
when you go up and buy a uh you up to
7-Eleven and you see like a jar for the
muscle Dystrophy and you take a piece of
candy and you leave a quarter or you
leave a dollar that's what this YouTube
channel is except instead of the dollar
all you gotta do is click like And
subscribe on on our little Channel and
we work for you and so our content's not
free you have to subscribe if you watch
more than one video and it's called The
Gentleman's Agreement because we're not
there it's a handshake so anyway that is
the gentleman's agreement so you do have
to subscribe to our Channel but dude
that pitch
changed everything immediately we
started close seeing close to a thousand
people a day clicking subscribe so it's
working so you got to have like a unique
way of asking for it and it's worked and
so now we have all types of people
coming up to us I had I was riding my I
was on a walk yesterday the guy drove by
and goes hey I honored the gentleman's
agreement
I swear to God in Austin I had two
people last week uh say that to me so
anyway that's our gentleman's agreement
so if you're listening if you've ever
listened to more than one episode
this is the gentleman's agreement it's
an honor System you have to do it and we
can't check this on you but please do it
everyone's doing it apparently if we're
growing almost a thousand a day but Nick
I appreciate you you're um
you uh what's the um what's the promo uh
it's a so support Shepherds the shepherd
thing yeah
sweatystartup.com boltstorage.com
support shepherd.com recast.com tax
credit hunter.com webbrun.com
titanrisk.com
and sweaty startup on
Twitter Twitter I mean I really
appreciate this I mean you bring me on
here I hope your audience got something
from this because the value that this
will add to me is is phenomenal man
you've always been incredibly supportive
I remember I was trying to launch a
little Community around real estate and
you got on a call when you were busy as
hell and I wasn't that big of a deal and
you helped me set that whole thing up I
mean the generosity uh Sam is freaking
awesome well I appreciate that and now
uh maybe one day I'm gonna ask to be an
affiliate of your affiliate or something
like that anything you need anything you
need man let me know
all right I appreciate you thank you
very much that's the that's the pod
foreign
[Music]